hi I'm John Cohen and we're going to do
a science live chat today about should
chimpanzees be studied in captivity
joining us are three wonderful
researchers who have all worked with
chimpanzees in different settings Brian
hare Pascal gallo and bill Hopkins
you're welcome to ask questions type
them in and we'll read them and the
different researchers will address them
I think you'll find that they have
interesting and different perspectives
so we'll start off with some questions
that people already have posted and
Brian Pascal and Bill just speak up and
if you'd like I can answer it um one one
of the questions is the difference
between laboratory experiments and
studies of chimpanzees in captivity and
wild chimpanzees which have been studied
for you know 50 years now closely so one
of the questions is what useful
information could be gleaned from
studying chimpanzee behavior in the wild
as opposed to the controlled laboratory
experiments and isn't the purpose of the
National Institutes of Health chimp
experimentation to use chimps as animal
models not to simply observe their
natural behavior oh well I'll take a
I'll take a first answer here I think
it's a little bit of a false dichotomy
to set it up as wild vs captive
observational or experimental research I
think there's valuable results that come
from both of those settings to
complement each other in many ways so
it's true the NAI the NIH's mission
isn't necessarily to to go out and have
people just watch the chimps and
although there's no reason that couldn't
be the case I'm one advantage that we
get out of some of the captive settings
that we can better control the kinds of
variables that would be difficult to
control or to eliminate in a wild
setting first of all and then second of
all I think is probably important
that certain kinds of studies are
certain experimental or scientific
questions are sometimes may be better
addressed or can be better addressed by
stud captive individuals instead of
those in the wild so there's just simply
some topics that lend themselves to a
captive setting in a slightly better
manner let's go you studied while chimps
in the tide forest and goat devore what
do you think well I think it's it's hard
to argue that a captive chimpanzees
especially a youngster growing up in a
setting that is incredibly can be
incredibly impoverished compared to the
wild it's that is that it's the same
situation so I kind of take the argument
from people who work exclusively with
wild chimpanzees that you know studying
development for example in a captive
setting you might miss the key things
that you have in the wild which is a
very complex social system at very
complex 3d scaffold of forests and
surprises and other living things but
i'd like to say word about the modeling
part because i actually think
chimpanzees are so interesting though
because they're a very good model i
think in many ways there are bad model
they are separate realization of a
hominid evolutionary trajectory and i
think that's what makes them so
interesting to study them not as a model
to model human disease but as a unique
view into how hominids including
ourselves evolved as a separate
realization of such an evolutionary
trajectory so Brian you're kind of at
the intersection of the two you've done
a lot of your work in sanctuaries where
there in Africa the sanctuaries mimic
the natural environment off and very
closely what do you think well the I
mean I think that you know we're
obviously here because the United States
and then I H is trying to figure out
what the future of chimpanzee research
is going to be and I just think that the
questions then asked in a funny way
again and again I don't think the
question is should chimpanzees be
studied in captivity the question is
where in captivity should they be
studied and you know the way that I see
it is that I think that you know Robert
yerkes who founded the first primate
Center and your keys with the bill works
at is named after
you wrote a paper in 1918 where he
suggested that we have primate centers
and bring primates the united states
including chimpanzees and other great
apes that was before we had you know the
ability to travel internationally
internet telephone etc so i just think
that we can do the exact same work that
we do in the regional primate centers we
can now do it on africa we can do it
just as well and we can do it for a lot
cheaper and we can make a big difference
in the life of conservation
organizations that are trying to protect
those animals so I think the debate
again I agree with Bill that you know
you need both wild and captive work the
question is do we still need the
laboratories to do the work that we want
to do it's all you are are you arguing
that we don't I well I certainly for
noninvasive work I don't think you I
don't think you really need it and
behavioural work now bill can speak to
it because I think this is a place where
he can make the argument that to do
serious neurobiological we're currently
imaging work for instance I mean
currently we have not published anything
in Africa on that but I just saw the
first MRI images from from the Republic
of Congo there were two chimpanzees they
were put in an MRI machine in Congo so
it's not impossible than in the future
if people got excited and wanted to
invest we could do it well so that leads
right into another question that someone
LG posted there are a variety of ways of
interpreting invasive when discussing
captive research and for example some
suggest removing a chimp from a group
and anesthetize her in order to do a
brain scan is non-invasive or that
implanting a therapeutic heart
monitoring device is non-invasive so
discussions of whether captive chimps
are justified seemed to suggest that if
research is non-invasive it's more
likely to be justified what what do you
three think about the definition of
invasive and where do you draw the line
I mean I saw for example at Yerkes I
observed a PET scan of a chimp that had
to be anesthetized for the pet scan and
it had to be intubated it wasn't harmed
in any way was that invasive so I'm
happy to go first and and i'll just say
I think a pretty conservative definition
is if it's in the interest of the
individual animal then you know if you
have animals in captivity you're going
to have to do regular veterinary work
and if it's in the interest of the
animal and then the question is if it's
in the interest of the species then I
don't see that as being particularly
invasive now in the case of the PET scan
you know I don't know I don't think that
necessarily hurt the animal but I don't
know if it was really in the interest of
the species it depends on how you define
interest of the species that are
interested individual then but I think
if it's if it's in interest to the ape
if it's health research veterinary
health research I I'm comfortable with
it I think it's a very difficult
question obviously and I doubt anybody
has the answer to it several years ago
RG Varkey Jim Mora and I'm trying to you
know come up with a way to help find a
question of what we would consider
acceptable for research and chimps and
for example it turns out cerebral spinal
fluid which you only get with spinal tap
it's pretty hard to get by and that
would be you know would this be ethical
and how you know you're quite happy to
do a study on humans where you take CSF
it's not there was a very low risk that
you know bad things could happen but
it's done regularly in humans so you
know I would be quite happy doing things
with chimpanzees that is routinely done
on on humans and that does not leave any
permanent damage and take that as a
criterium whether I would do this in
Japan and captive chimpanzees or not
though where you've actually share very
similar opinions to pastels view you
know we try to use you know the
guidelines that are used with human
subjects and we try at least in our work
we try to apply those in the questions
and the kind of questions or research
we're doing with the chimp so you know I
i I'm I have a very similar view to
pascals about what defines invasive it's
interesting because the Institute of
Medicine committee that reviewed this
and the NIH accepted their
recommendations
it didn't narrow it down to what Pascal
is essentially saying which is if you
could ethically do something on a human
in a research research study you can
ethically do it in a chimpanzee am i
hearing you right esque out that the
essence of it well i would add something
possibly to kind of solidify the ethics
and we had initially proposed to write
this and you know i think if you
consider it ethical you should be ready
to do it on yourself I actually think
experiment on humans much more and we
should have the scientists performing
the experiments be part of it because if
somebody asks you to volunteer for an
experiment and you ask them back if they
are one of the volunteers and they say
no I would not volunteer it's kind of
the basic golden rule that I was so if
you if you do CSF studies and
chimpanzees you need human controls you
one of the controls unless you have some
clinical reason not that's very very
anything bill there's a question
directed specifically to you that gets
back to something the Brian rate is and
the question is why continue to study
chimps and Darren laboratory
environments where they when they can be
observed in the wild or in more complex
captive environment such as sanctuaries
and why does it matter that we know
which hand a chimp prefers to use and
isn't there a point where well-being in
rights of chimpanzees outweigh the need
to satisfy our curiosity via controlled
experiments um okay I'm not sure which
part of that two-part question you want
me to go let's start with what Brian was
raising I mean why why the earth okay
well I think in a global sense whether
you're working in a sanctuary in Africa
and a sanctuary in the US or in a
laboratory setting in the u.s. you're
still working with captive animals all
right and ultimately and for example in
the sanctuaries a temper trend a number
of those settings those animals are
orphaned all right and which is really
the principal problem that leads to some
of the psychological issues that some of
that captive animals might have all
right so you know I don't necessarily
think that that that this idea that one
setting well first of all I wouldn't
even go so far as to say that that every
laboratory setting is incredibly
impoverished I do believe we should do
you more everyone should be doing more
to improve the physical housing
and the psychological well-being of all
primates notch or two counties in
captivity we should be striving to to
have settings that you know rival what
we can have in the wild but I don't
necessarily necessarily see that moving
for example my research program to a
sanctuary in Africa would necessarily
get me any different results or any
better results well I think the point
though that the that the person was
asking the Bryan's making is you could
do it in Africa so why do it it in a
setting that is not as close to the
natural environment because first of all
they're here in the 30 pansies are here
and they're in other places in the US
and they're they're not going anywhere
and I think it would be in many ways to
just leave them sitting there and doing
nothing with them in some ways is is
somewhat ethically questionable as well
I think we you know with the doing
cognitive studies with the animals is
enriching to them and and I think to
just say well you know we can do it in
Africa in a physical environment we
think is better and psychologically
better for these it when we don't really
have any scientific to demonstrate that
scientific evidence that demonstrates
that I think is is is probably it you
know not a good decision at this point I
think we have the resources here and
it's in our best interest to sort of
invest in those resources now instead of
moving these operations to another
continent Ron what do you think you
think that your keys should retire all
these chimps and the other facilities
that house captive Chim Cheree tire them
off well I don't know about your keys I
mean I can circle back to that but I
certainly think that there's a huge
opportunity and I just want to make sure
that people are aware and please go to
ape research org it's a pre search org
and that's a website where basically
everybody who does non-invasive works
that's not in a u.s. nih-funded
laboratory has formed a consortium and
we've posted all the publications
since 2006 that we've that we've
published and I think that websites
really important because what in the
debate over the future of chimpanzee
research in captivity it's often been if
the NIH closes their facilities there
will be no more chimpanzee research that
I've heard that said over and over and
over and over again and so that's why we
built the website was to say that
actually the vast majority of research
that's non-invasively chimpanzees it
doesn't even occur in the NIH labs and
because the NIH has a big voice they've
been able to say that over and over
again and all sorts of position papers
but what I would hope in the future
would happen is there's a much more
cost-effective way to do research in
Africa at sanctuaries there's over 20 of
them there's over 1,500 apes that are
orphans of the bushmeat trade and by
supporting these organizations in Africa
we're actually helping protect wild
chimpanzees we can do the same or
actually in many ways better research in
Africa then we can in the labs there are
some questions we can't answer currently
and I do you know and I think that
absolutely that's true but there a lot
of questions that we can answer that you
cannot answer in a laboratory just for
instance nobody has bonobos so we have
two closest relatives not one and
because the NIH has taken a model
species approach they chose the chimp
which in many ways was a really bad
decision because bonobos have probably a
lot of the psychological underpinnings
that we have they're more similar to
many of the diseases we want to study
but we chose the wrong species so if we
study bonobos we study them in Africa we
help protect them in Africa we can also
help protect our own health it's a win
win win win win um just can I just say
something the please I mean I'm not
opposed to anyone who wants to go work
in a sanctuary with the chimpanzee sir
and they want to do behavioral or
cognitive or search I have no troubles
with that I really am interested in the
people who want to stay here and do that
work and I think you know that that you
know it's you know there's a lot we can
do here that that would
chimpanzees as well that has benefited
chimpanzees as well and we you know we
should be we should be supportive of
that and the apes are hearing they're
not going anywhere and I think we need
to be investing in that and and I think
there's many settings you know again
going back to this idea that the
environments are really parent I think
there are a number of facilities in the
u.s. research laboratories that are
housing chimpanzees their rival many
sanctuary settings so I don't I don't
think you know it's as glorious as as it
sometimes can be portrayed so there's
been cutting back on chimpanzee research
for many years now in the United States
with NIH funding I remember when I start
writing about chimpanzee research the
NIH was breeding chimpanzees for AIDS
vaccine research they stopped that in
nineteen ninety seven or so with the
moratorium I I wonder whether the recent
events have at all impaired the research
that you're doing bill or Pascal that
you do with biological samples from
chimpanzees has it become harder and if
so what type of research isn't happening
that might be happening and what's the
cost of cutting back on chimpanzee
research so I think I think it's clear
that that the idea that we were pretty
much done with chimpanzees so you know
the thousand or so individuals let live
in the u.s. if they go to sanctuaries
the male's get sterilized we end up with
you know aging chimpanzees and talking
about non enriched environments lack of
youngsters would be a very big way to to
make an environment much cooler for
example but you know sanctuaries insist
on the fact that they don't want more
chimps and you next generation of gems
there it has made it much more difficult
to get to biological samples i would i
would really support a builds point that
i would think it's unethical not to give
the chimpanzees in u.s. actuaries the
best possible medical care including
research because there is so much we
don't know about them as I you know I
want to reiterate that James in many
ways are bad models they died of
completely different diseases than we do
yet they're being treated like little
humans using
human medical books and so forth so I
apples of that well the famous thing is
the so-called and heart attacks these
cardiomyopathies that that kill a lot of
chimpanzees they drop dead and it looks
like a heart attack but it has nothing
to do with the human heart attack it's
something in the muscles that scar
tissue in the muscle of these chimps so
it looks so far away like they're having
a heart attack but it's not at all the
same type of cardiovascular disease that
is one of the biggest killers in humans
and they actually do to bring biomedical
difference in in the wild of course and
that that includes sanctuaries you have
a lot of contact between humans and the
chimpanzees so we are bringing in
potentially nasty diseases the sanctuary
we have two wild study populations and
chimpanzees might react very differently
as as has been shown for the new more
viruses and the respiratory syncytial
virus in West Africa but there's some
evidence that the very people who study
the wild chimpanzees and try to protect
them might be infecting them with pretty
nasty viruses that are not nasty in us
necessarily but very nasty other
chimpanzees so I think we really attic
Lee we are obliged to study them more
both for their own sake and for our
understanding of human origins though
what would work as your work being
curtailed at all and if so what
specifically aren't you able to do that
you would like to do because of the
cutback and funding and support of
captive chim for search oh well my work
has not been affected that much for the
most part but I do think that we are
very limited esque I already mentioned
this the fact that we're not reading and
haven't for a while you know we we have
an areas of developmental research you
know what is the time course of brain
development for example in relation to
behavioral development and things like
this we haven't really been able to do
anything like this and and that's
probably one significant limitation of
some of the decisions at NIH has made
regarding the management of the captive
population Brian there's a question that
is very basic but I think it's worth
addressing because we have a broad
audience here and please if you're
watching do ask us questions
the difference between an eighth-minute
sanctuary in Africa and an eighth and a
sanctuary in the US okay so the US has a
lot of sanctuaries that house Apes they
were either bred for the entertainment
industry or at it have been taken from
people who had them as pets some of them
have been collected from laboratories
and chimp haven for instance is where
the United States government created a
sanctuary and retired a number of
chimpanzees several hundred actually and
so that's a u.s. sanctuary so those are
animals that basically are no longer
either being used as pets and
entertainment or in laboratories and so
either a private NGO has take footed the
bill or the taxpayer has footed the bill
a sanctuary in Africa is a there there
20 of them there's an organization
called the pan-african sanctuary
Alliance and those organizations each
each of the 20 have been operating as
conservation and welfare organizations
there's a a raging bushmeat trade in
Africa literally thousands of
chimpanzees are being killed each year
we're anybody who's worried about eight
conservation and Africa is very worried
about the growing footprint of China
right now we know that 100 chimpanzees
were poached or not sorry the poach but
were we're sold to the Chinese from
Guinea funneled through Guinea and ended
up in China so basically there's a
there's an organization that's trying to
stop the bushmeat trade try to stop
people from killing endangered apes in
Africa they they give these animals
lifetime care when they're confiscated
particularly when they're young so you
have a very young population usually
they're confiscated at around the age of
2 to 3 and they're given lifetime care
and they have wonderful large spaces as
much as a hundred acres of primary
tropical forest they live in they live
in multi male multi female groups they
can forge all day but then they come
into housing at night and because they
don't like to get rained on they're not
they're not stupid they like to stay
inside and
and what that means is in the morning
you can ask them if they want to play
games and so we can do our cognitive
work then it's all voluntary if they
don't want to play we let them go out
and they can live their normal life but
then of course they need veterinary care
as well and so we have a lot of
opportunities there to collect data I
just want to go to the biological
sampling question really quickly and say
that we have collected uh we've cloned
genomes of over 100 individuals we have
collected hormone assays testosterone
and cortisol we have done w labeled
water in the sanctuaries which is a
measure of metabolism and so we're not
just doing behavioural work we're doing
all sorts of physiological and
morphological and behavioural work in
cognitive work so there's a lot of
opportunity oh let's let's get to a very
practical aspect of this Pascal can you
access those samples only if I you know
if I get my own site ease permit or work
with people who have a size permit and
you need permits from both the exporting
nations and the importing nations is
that hard to do the it depends who you
are and how connected you are the father
permit now in the u.s. you actually have
to prove that you directly are involved
in conservation of the species in
question so if I'm interested in cheap
in chimpanzee genomes I have to convince
the psyches authorities of the u.s. that
my work will in some way directly
contribute to the future conservation to
the conservation of these chimpanzees or
other Apes so just to put a fine point
on it it's easier for you to get samples
from chimps in captivity here than from
chimps in a few less yes however um
interestingly there is a situs has now
started regulating interstate traffic
even though it's really it's an
international convention right side is
but societies officials in the US now
are interested like to know if you move
chimpanzee samples from one side of the
u.s. to the other so the same has added
a whole new layer of permits needed
Sadie's is CI tes it's an acronym for an
international treaty
regul that reagan that actually stopped
the importation of wild chimpanzees by
researchers to outside of africa or at
least it tried to and and i think for
the most part it succeeded um there's a
question that builds off what we're
talking about what somebody's asking
about hogan is asking about bill raising
the point that we should invest more in
the captive chimps here and asks
wouldn't it be possible for there to be
a collaboration between researchers
working in sanctuaries in africa with
those working here in the US to improve
the captive conditions in the US with
the end goal of species conservation
could more be done that have bill and
Brian and Pascal all working together
with the same angle in mind absolutely I
see no reason and in fact I mean this is
what often concerns me is that is that
you know persons who are studying wild
chimpanzees you know it becomes this
sort of unfortunate barricade or there's
this sort of notion that somehow you
know you know if you're studying a
captive chin peers you're doing
something less than if you're studying a
wild chimp okay and I as I I'm just
going to go back on what I said earlier
I think these can complement each other
and it the same applies with the
sanctuary situations i think you know
instead of some of the ideas that the
working group has proposed which is to
build these brand-new sanctuaries and
and and to spend a lot of money to do
this to retire these animals it would be
it would be better served in many ways
to take where we have Jim Seto in
research settings and provide funding to
those institutions to expand their
facilities that they would so that they
would become more close to what's in the
wild Orion some of the African
sanctuaries if we think that the just
simply expanding the physical space and
the physical environment is enough to
satisfy those who feel communal that
really want these kinds of changes made
and think it has a real benefit on the
well-being of the animals a question has
come in from row row and please if
you're watching send us your questions
roro apparently works at chimp haven and
sanctuary united states and ask why it
has to be either sanctuaries in Africa
or sanctuaries in
the US shouldn't we be making the most
of all chimpanzees in captivity while
they're still while ensuring that they
have the best environments possible and
the chimpanzees are in the US for better
or worse for the rest of their lives do
you have access to researchers have
access to do research studies with
chimps at chimp haven and if so can you
get the types of samples you want if
their biological I mean what's really
available and what are the limitations
Oh is there anyone in particular you
like answer that well I mean I I think
that you know Brian you could do
researcher chimp haven if you were
allowed to can you is it possible well I
think the the first thing is that um the
bio metalcraft biomedical community
people who are interested in invasive
research on chimpanzees to study human
health they've been very critical of
champion and they've said that chimp
haven has been very restrictive in their
regulations of what research would be
allowed I actually don't agree with that
I think that they've said you can do
non-invasive work as long as it's
observational in nature and there's a
lot of people who do that type of work
and if you're interested in elderly
chimpanzees that have been released into
a new environment and watching how they
flexibly adapt to that new environment
if you're interested in how chimpanzees
for new relationships with one another
if you're you know interested in how to
increase the welfare of those animals
then it's a fantastic place to do
research I think that there's a lot of
opportunity my understanding is nobody
has actually yet applied to work there
last I spoke to the folks at chimp haven
six eight months ago they repeatedly
it's repeatedly said over and over by um
actually quite high up people that I've
been in rooms with them they've said it
that no one could ever do any research a
chimp haven I don't understand why
because on their own website there is a
research application you can go and
apply so maybe people will have applied
and they've rejected them but I don't
understand but I just want to go back to
the question about just really quickly
bill was saying about why can't we just
all do our research and all you know
excited about each other's research I am
I think bill does great work I think
Pascal does great work but there's
reality there's the real world the real
world is that there's a tiny tiny tiny
amount of money to do this type of work
and it's getting smaller and smaller all
the time and the when you look at the
cost benefit of you know the publication
for dollar I think you can do much
better in Africa than you can with aging
infrastructure that was built in the 60s
and it was built before Jane Goodall
went to the field and I think it would
be horrific if there was breeding in the
United States again in the biomedical
facilities I think that would be just a
major waste of money because for for the
amount of money that it takes to keep
animals in the United States it's just a
drop in that we could just do amazing
things with with that money in Africa it
just to just to be concrete it's you
know I've never had a penny from the
National Institute of Health to study
the great apes that we work with in
Africa I've gone to the NSF and if you
get money from the National Science
Foundation I can promise you you're not
getting as much money as you are if you
go to the NIH and get an ro1 so so if I
can go and do my work on an NSF budget I
promise you it's cheaper well yeah
Pascal do you have any thoughts about
the possibilities of you doing your
research with samples from chimp haven
is it something you've explored yes so
you know I know that Linda branch which
I think just that she just stepped down
from directing Jim haven but she was
always very open to the type of you know
sample collection that is totally
non-invasive evil either done during
routine care or more importantly
actually post mortems and and and you
know samples collected when an animal
died died of a natural death and and I
think that brings up a big question
where there's a lot of wasted
opportunities I mean we have a very
strange situation in the US where we
have most chimpanzees that are in
sanctuaries that are sterilized and then
you've got a small population in zoos
that every zoo is trying to have as many
babies as they can in both cases we end
up with animals that sometimes died and
many of these of
Unity's are not you know taking
advantages of our knowledge of basic
great a biology is lacking in so many
respects that any passing of a great ape
should be very closely monitored and
then out of respect of both the
individual and the knowledge we would
like to glean from these species we
should perform perfect offices on on the
on the great apes that died in captivity
and very oh it's not happening is that
because the institutions aren't playing
aren't playing along there are playing
ball they don't want to share with with
I think there's a variety of reason that
the the simplest reason is that you know
these animals die on Sundays or
Christmas even and and for a good
autopsy it has to happen in ED Utley
many of the tissues will authorize their
rapidly so really what should be in
place and and and you know I'm not
trying to put the onus on Jim hey and i
think the researchers should step up and
fun you know regional pathologist or
people who can step in and when they are
told we have an animal that looks like
it might die that then every care is
taken to to maximize these samples I
mean I i participated in in some of
these collections LA Zoo for example had
an individual that died and he's one of
the 78 apes that just got his genome
sequence because they called us up and
they said this animal is dying and so we
performed an immediate post mortem and
collected as many samples as we could in
best fashion possible to maximize the
the biological information I thought I
think there should be much more of that
irrespective of the setting and I'm very
hopeful that this is possible in Africa
and Brian I have had a lot of
discussions I think he's totally right
that the Africans sanctuaries are a
phenomenal resource but I wouldn't put
it either all I think you know the
thousand-plus Apes that are here are
here and not studying them i think is
unethical so we're talking about the
future of research with chimpanzees both
in captivity and in the world which
being with Brian hare Pascal gallo and
Bill Hopkins and one of the questions
comes from Dan who asked whether the
recent decisions about curtailing
chimpanzee research with captive
chimpanzees will affect HIV research
significantly and I mentioned this a few
minutes ago chimpanzees were the model
for HIV vaccine research for many years
at the beginning of the isolation of HIV
in 1984 shortly thereafter the virus was
put into chimps and it was vigorously
studied in chimpanzees for until the
early 1990s and that all stopped and we
now also know that there's a version of
HIV it's called simian SIV cpz that
likely kills chimpanzees from an AIDS
like disease which we didn't know years
ago so I'm going to put a question to
the three of you that I think it's
provocative that I've thought of often
when Brian you mentioned doing
experiments to help the animals would it
be ethical to do SIV cpz experiments in
captive chimpanzees to develop a vaccine
that ultimately would help both humans
and vaccines and chimpanzees and bonobos
for that matter although they haven't
ever been found with SIV cpz would that
be ethical to do a vaccine experiment
that would be similarly done in a human
except let's say you just wanted to look
at the immune responses you didn't want
to put SIV CPC into the animal that you
wanted to see what immune responses
would this vaccine stimulate would that
be ethical can I just jump in really
quick and just say that um the I think
the first question would be do you have
to do it on the chimpanzee or the bonobo
I mean I'm not a vaccine researcher but
I know that that's the first thing you
know people who are welfare advocates
that would be what they would want to
know and and truthfully every US
researcher should be a welfare advocate
that's legally what we should be doing
is at all times not trying to avoid
using animals in any situation where we
don't need to use them so I think that's
the first question is what can you do it
using a new technique using a different
model species and once you've answered
that question if then the answer is you
can only do it with chimpanzees and
bonobos okay now we've got your question
okay let me let me let me put a fine
point on it here's the experiment the
way the chimpanzee experiments with AIDS
vaccines were done for many years
to give them an HIV vaccine and then to
inject them with HIV and HIV by and
large doesn't cause harm in chimpanzees
we now know because it's not adapted to
them but what if you were to do it with
SIV cpz and then put the chimpanzee who
became that became infected on to
antiretroviral drugs to keep the
chimpanzee alive and relatively healthy
would that be ethical given that that
experiment would never be done in a
human and yet it might help both species
anyone want to touch that one well I i
can try you got i have big doubts
because the the big question is
applicable t you would need large
numbers and would you ever want to go in
and treat wild chimpanzees with a
vaccine that might be half baked and and
i know there is some talk of possibly
you know treating wild chimpanzees with
Ebola vaccines and so forth but it's a
the numbers you need to test vaccines in
humans or you know you would need more
than all the African sanctuaries
combined to test the you one vaccine
candidate and given the history of human
HIV vaccines that it doesn't vote too
well now I used by two different s IV c
pz in east africa and in central Africa
so even though the in chimpanzees you
have quite different SIV cpz strains so
I just think it's not realistic I you
know I think that answers the question I
wouldn't stop doing it because there's
no way you would have enough animals and
then be able to actually go and treat
animals in the wild well because how the
old experiments could get statistical
significance with you know four to eight
animals and you know it I don't know I
mean in the past that's how it was done
Brian you were gonna say something yeah
I was just going to say I have talked to
the sum of the directors in the
pan-african sanctuary Alliance about you
know diseases they're really worried
about I mean we have animals that died
in Africa of horrible things there's a
virus called emc V that killed 10 bows
and it's a pretty horrific death um and
and so you know there's a bola there's
Marburg there's there's everything
could could be terrified of as a person
no great apes can get it as a captive 8
manager in Africa you're worried about
those same diseases so when you talk to
them about okay well what would you do
or if we found out there were
individuals infected with these viruses
um you know first of all they're
interested in willing to participate in
research that will prevent the spread
that will help us understand these
viruses better and you know if if there
was a vaccine that was really risky that
somebody thought might work on an animal
that was already naturally infected I
think they would go for it but I think
the idea that you would go to a
sanctuary and in fact one of the
sanctuary Apes with Ebola intentionally
to then test the vaccine that then gets
really tricky I what I want to be clear
I'm not advocating this it's just that
in the past I think my question it's
what it was routine in the past that's
what the model was for and to do things
that you wouldn't do in a human um row
row from Chimp Haven has several
comments online i'd encourage everyone
to read them and roro i would argue that
you are part of this conversation so I
wouldn't worry about it that's the
beauty of new media Andrew asks a
question that says the question is
really asking whether it's wrong to
domesticate any living thing and then
study it I think that's an interesting
point though what do you think I mean to
you how do we draw lines here between
great apes and any other species well I
guess I wouldn't really consider the
chimps to be domesticated and in the way
that say a cow or a dog might be
domesticated I mean haven't been
selectively bred for specific kinds of
traits I mean as far as we know the
chimpanzees that of our in captivity in
the u.s. you know they're all from you
know a fairly diverse genetic pool of
you know that came from the wild and so
i'm not sure that i would say that we
are really studying a domesticated
animal yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
consider it to be a domesticated animal
either so the question ro-ro's asking
now is whether federal funds are going
to be made available to
care for chimps that have been used in
biomedical research in this country and
we're and we're saying that these apes
are living in substandard housing and
currently NIH funding for research with
captive chimpanzees helps pay for their
care are these chimpanzees going to find
themselves in an even worse situation if
NIH funding for research is cut off any
thoughts on that I think the answer is
yes but I think right now you know in
many instances the support for the
animals is coming from research that's
funded with them so if the NIH which is
it not my interpretation at all of what
the IOM has has has suggested or the
working group for that matter but i do
think if they if they were to just say
we're not going to fund another
chimpanzee research project whether it
be hahira genomics imaging or anything
else yeah i think i think these animals
will lose in that proposition Brian do
any thoughts about it you I imagine are
supportive of the act of the emphasis to
move more timpz into retirement and to
cut the type of research funding that's
been going on for those are good the
reason that I didn't answer before about
retirement is that I completely agree
with Bill and Pascal I think that
there's no problem studying the
chimpanzees that are in laboratories I
just wish that they could be retired or
improve the laboratories so that they're
nicer and in some ways that has been
done i visited some and I mean it's not
as bad as it was before it still could
be way way way better so you know I do
think there's been real efforts there to
improve things but I mean it's a light
years away from what it could be so I so
when you say retire I mean I think why
we're having this conversation is
chimpanzees used to be intentionally
infected with diseases and and that's
really what's going to stop happening
and all the other stuff like what bill
does and what Pascal does I mean we're
studying human evolution we're trying to
understand um you know laterality in the
brain which is super important what bill
does I mean understanding whether they
have left to right hand biases is
crucially important if you want to stand
language if
won't understand all sorts of other
things so if you mean by retire them
that they're no longer are going to be
infected with diseases because there are
other models that are more effective
than yes if retirement means that you
lock them away forget them and nobody
takes care of them and bill can't go do
non-invasive research well that's silly
because I mean ultimately bill and I do
almost the exact same thing you know but
but what worries me is if literally we
spend tens of millions of dollars on
these chimpanzees and we could be
spending even a quarter of that and
absolutely quintuple the research that
we do if we work in another place and I
just want to be really super concrete is
and Bill and Pascal can correct me but I
don't I think that I don't think there's
been anybody the only thing that's more
in danger than the captive laboratory
chimpanzee is the captive laboratory
chimpanzee researcher I don't think
there's been anybody who's gotten tenure
I don't think there's been any
tenure-track jobs and so the only people
that I know who've gotten tenure in the
last 45 years have been I have one
student who just got a tenure-track job
and I got tenure so I just don't think
there's a future because of the funding
situation so I think that if if its just
oh we're going to use the tiny little
bit of money on to just keep doing what
we're doing I just don't we will not
have a field anymore there are no
students there's good you raised a very
interesting pointing the disease
research really was where most the
funding was coming from and let other
behavioral stuff and neurocognitive
stuffs with piggybacking total and so
now you're in a situation where the
institute of medicine is giving
direction to the National Institutes of
Health and you're not hearing the NIH
say this is an incredibly valuable
resource that we want to keep supporting
at the same level they're saying most of
these studies are unnecessary or many of
them are not host let me correct that
many are unnecessary and that you know
we should maybe even dwindle it down to
50 captive chimpanzees available for
researchers and do you think there's
a lack of recalculation of resources
given the move away from that disease
model I would say yes but I defer to my
colleagues here I'm certainly I'm
certainly afraid of that um how about
you bill well I'm trying to just dissect
your question a little bit so I guess
you know my view is maybe we haven't
been very good advocates for what we do
and I agree when you know I don't think
that the amount of funding coming from
NIH to support biomedical research with
jim was all that great I've been you
know in this field a long time and I
think there's there's more funding
available for doing chimp behavior brain
genetics now then there has been in the
past and you know I think that's a good
sign and I think if we have were better
advocates for what we were doing maybe
there would be more support for that and
and I think there's more interest now
than there was an a so so in some sense
i mean i agree that there it's really
unfortunate that at some level and I
just saying I mean I guess for me i
guess i haven't interpreted anything
from nih it says I don't that they don't
want to continue to fund research in
cognition in genomics in neurobiology I
mean that that it wasn't what I took
away from the IOM what I took away from
the IOM report was you know there really
wasn't a lot of support for the need of
chimps in HIV or or malaria or other
forms of research with where where they
have been historically used so I guess I
have a slightly different take on you
know how the funding sort of has changed
over the years in my view you know given
that we've done the chimp genome now
we've made so much connection progress
in in non-invasive ways of doing imaging
the this is the time we should be
investing in these resources not not
scaling back because I think we're
really on the cusp of a lot of really
important discoveries that everyone
participating this head has been
involved in just to be believed it
ih hasn't finalized his decision yet
about the IOM report in the working
group that studied it for the NIH and
the Council of councils that should
happen in the next few weeks so it's
unclear I think still what the NIH is
going to do Brian did you want to say
something or I'm just going to say again
the question is what resources to invest
in do you invest in resources that cost
tens of millions of dollars to upkeep
every year or do you invest in resources
that actually all you have to do is pay
for the actual research itself it'll
cost you much much less and we can do as
hard-hitting science and in fact in many
ways we can do better science you know
not only has the chimpanzee genome been
done now the bonobo Gino has been done
it was not done in an NIH laboratory it
was done in Leipzig and it was done at
lowly a bonobo because we sent a sample
out um so the you know there are amazing
things that can be done in sanctuaries
that cannot be done in the NIH
facilities anymore and for me I just I
think that you're going to if we decide
to maintain status of these aging
facilities you're going to be throwing a
lot of money that you could do you could
use much more effectively to do
non-invasive work that would help not
just people but also the Apes and let me
just go back really quickly to the
emerging infectious disease problem is
the sanctuaries are at the front line of
emerging infectious disease prevention
and potential research if if people
would take it seriously the bushmeat
trade obviously we talked about HIV and
where did that come from well you know
one of the hypotheses is it was the
bushmeat trade um that you know people
were eating primates and somebody got
infected that way and then it spread
from there so we now have an increase in
that trait we have you know all sorts of
potential viruses etc that can be
entering into populations and if we
invest in that we could not only prevent
the next pandemic but we could help save
great apes study cognition behavior
physiology morphology you get a lot more
bang for your buck than you do if you
just keep going with you know the
current
setting that we have if you could fund
both great but I just don't think that's
realistic there as a question from
Marcos do you think that the Humane
Society the United States is having too
much of an influence over the direction
of medical research in the United States
and the Humane Society has advocated
strongly for stopping certainly invasive
biomedical research with chimpanzees
does anyone have thoughts about that
well I'm having talked about it but I've
been talking too much so maybe somebody
else what to say I haven't had a lot of
interactions go ahead pascal from from
personal experience when when ajith
varkey jumuah and i wrote this paper on
the ethical consideration of captive
chip research we got you know massive
reactions from two extreme side one side
saying chimpanzee should have human
rights and who were we to advocate
studying them and the other side of oh
you're on a slippery slope you will end
up with the animal rights fanatics and
we kind of took that as a compliment and
said we might be somewhere near a
reasonable you know position on what to
do with chimpanzees but it's almost
impossible you it's it's clear that it's
a it's a topic that totally dichotomized
is people are lots of extremely loud
people on both extremes that's setting I
need my chamber aim to drill in and you
are a Nazi because you consider taking a
blood sample from a captive chimpanzee
and that's very rapidly where you find
yourself if you advocate you know a an
increased interest in in in following
you know health research in chimpanzees
by taking samples but not in a way you
wouldn't do in a normal human well I've
just riff on Pascal and say that in my
experience um it certainly has been the
case that things get dichotomized and
who suffers as a result are the animals
I think that people do not treat welfare
seriously they think that you see in the
newspaper all time you'll have somebody
who's talking about welfare and they get
called an animal rights activist and and
if you if you
you care at all of that welfare as a
researcher people all of a sudden think
that you're against invasive research in
any context under any circumstance and
so I think that we need to start
thinking about welfare like the Red
Cross there's you know there's two
people battling it out about the ethics
but at the same time there's this whole
thing of welfare it's the guy who is
actually putting the tourniquet on the
injured individual you don't shoot it
that guy while you're fighting your war
and and so you know I think that in many
ways in my experience I think the Humane
Society has been the only group that has
been doing anything that looks like
welfare now I know that they may veer in
other ways that disturb people but if
there was a if there was a more moderate
group then I would be really excited
about them too but there isn't one
except for and and and partly that's
because um there's this dichotomy and I
would say it's at universities too I
mean professors who do a super invasive
work on primates which you know if it's
necessary if there's no other way I'm
supportive of they can be very
aggressive if you start talking about
champion chimpanzee welfare so I I don't
for me I think that's the big issue is
people have forgotten there's this thing
called welfare hmm Stephanie asks can do
you name any diseases or invasive
research that are still necessary and
are there studies where there's no
alternative except to use chimpanzees I
mean hepatitis C has been the central
model the chimpanzee has been the
central model for that research
community for many years and there is no
vaccine for hepatitis D what what are
you three think I mean is there anything
you can point to that you think you make
a strong argument that it's important to
continue to do invasive research I mean
my guess is that that you three people
don't have anything at the top of your
agenda that you think is necessary
that's bordering on invasive but but
tell me what you think well I I'm not a
biomechanical worker so I I don't have a
good answer for that I think the people
that do that work can make those
arguments the best and I think they did
a you know there was a lot of discussion
about this in the IOM reading and I
think you know there were a couple of
instances where some cases could be made
for for the use of chimps in some
research monoclonal antibodies comes to
mind remember specifically what that was
targeted word but they're there seemed
to be some you know some individuals
among the group of individuals there
advocating that there is a need for
chimps and some of that hepatitis C I
think the island was really split on
that to me at least that was my
impression from the report you know some
were advocating maybe there were some
mouse models now that might be better
for this but still I think some of the
representatives from some of the larger
vaccine centers were thinking you know
yes we still might need a chimp or tube
for some of this kind of work but I mean
as i said i know this does not relieve
my area so it would be difficult for me
to give it a very informed answer know
there was a researcher i spoke with some
years ago who pointed out to me that he
had actually overseen a monoclonal
antibody experiment in a chimpanzee that
harmed the chimp that cause serious harm
and it was about to be tested in humans
and he said this was exactly what the
model was supposed to do that was
preventing harm in humans at that very
last date where there was no other
alternative and his argument was
wouldn't you rather see the chimpanzee
injured than a human but i think that
argument has fallen out of fashion if
not ethical sort of evolution that
that's occurred but but i'm curious
whether anyone else thinks that i think
that you stuck with that I'm you via me
yeah um so I think you stuck with
testing many things in humans but we are
our best model animal so no matter how
many things you test the naim animals in
the end you will need to test it on
humans volunteer you sometimes passively
volunteered as for example when
government volunteer population and and
and I think that's a question that's
very rarely address
especially by animal rights advocates we
usually don't you know line up to to
volunteer for vaccine tests I think all
of us have to our app to ask ourselves
that if we develop vaccines for humans
we can't just ship that out to Uganda or
to China or to India you know it used to
be the Swiss government volunteered its
population or the Soviet Union
volunteered its population and we have
to ask ourselves you know we're trying
to test medication for our species that
has its you its unique trajectory
especially with regard to immunology
very different from mice and very
different from chimpanzees in many ways
so in the end you you will have to test
it in humans no matter what and I don't
have an answer for that but I'm kind of
annoyed by the fact that nobody
addresses the fact that in the end you
will need you cohort of humans that you
test it on you no matter what so we only
have a few minutes left I have one
question for each of you the same
question the population of chimpanzees
that exists in captivity now without
active breeding it will disappear that
they cannot possibly be sustained there
have been several studies that have
looked at that and with a date of 20 31
being the end date what's your vision of
the future here for the captive
chimpanzees that are here some of which
are owned by the US government and at
chimp haven what's your what's your
vision what happens 10 20 years down the
road to captive chimpanzees outside of
the zoo setting in the United States
which houses more than anywhere we
should make that clear so let's start
with Brian what do you think what's your
vision well for me I mean I think that
it's fine if the population goes extinct
I don't think they're necessary I don't
think we need them for anything I think
there are thousands of chimpanzees in
captivity in Africa I think that zoos
have hundreds of chimpanzees and I think
we have plenty I'm more worried about
bonobos I think that that's where we're
really in shortage and I think that's
what people i mean people never talk
about that but we have two closest
relatives and we have no access to
bonobos what a disaster so for me the
future is lots more bonobos I think
we're fine with chimpanzees that's going
I'm puzzled by the the fact that a lot
of people can [ __ ] you know welcome
the extinction of a large population of
an endangered species I i really wonder
if our descendants and one day we'll ask
oh these guys had a thousand endangered
apes in the US and they decided for
their welfare to let them age and become
geriatric so i would actually think it
would make a lot of sense for the
well-being of these chimps to allow very
limited breathing so that there is a
young generation around the the
geriatrics don't what you did you yeah I
tend to agree with Pascal to some extent
I do think that you know there are a lot
of chimps in captivity that are owned by
a man by an age and that that colony is
going to dwindle I mean there's there's
no doubt about that just through
attrition and other kinds of things but
I hope in the future that we have a
relatively large sustainable colony of
chimps in optimal housing settings we
have breeding we have something that
resembles both social system and
physical environment of the wild and I
really hope that we can get a much
larger infusion of research support from
NSF NIH and the private sector in
studying chimpanzees in the future
because as I said earlier I think in my
view there's you know much more interest
now than there was 20 years ago in
people doing research with chimpanzees
and I think that I'm gonna I'm gonna try
to be optimistic about that all right
well Brian Pascal and Bill I thank you
so much for taking the time to discuss
it it's a tricky topic if the nuanced
topic for anyone viewing the chat will
remain archived on the page if you want
to read it watch it later and next week
there'll be a chat on june sixth about
what it will take to get humans to Mars
with a buzz aldrin thank you three so
much for joining in anything Thank You
huge hi everyone my room okay